kevin what is up my wife and
mother-in-law
um haven't spoken really since about
february march of this year um and this
is the first
kind of holiday season without them
talking to each other
um i want to try to be the best husband
i can for my wife
and i i know that my own mental
capacity i try to fix things all the
time so i'm trying to see
what's the best thing i can do how's the
best way i can be supportive for her
so why aren't they talking
um well it kind of goes back a little
ways but
my my mother-in-law struggles with
alcohol abuse
this kind of spring and summer
she went into a couple rehab facilities
i think about i can't remember how many
different ones but
the first one she was kind of forced
into by my sister-in-law
um and because she came over to our
house when we
set the boundary of not uh having any
alcohol in the house and she brought
alcohol into our house
so we kind of cut off communication
there because we have little ones
yeah you don't need the absolute right
thing there i'm proud of you for that
good for you thank you good for you um
so bring me two how can i help you guys
right now
is is your wife just struggling
crumbling under that broken relationship
or how are you caught in the middle of
this
so we've we've gone and we've helped her
set up a couple counseling sessions with
a christian counselor um it's been going
good but i
i noticed around thanksgiving that it
was eating her it was eating at her a
little bit
um that she wasn't seeing her mom um
i don't know if it was a part of guilt
um i don't know if it was just
missing her um but i know that it was
it was eating her and um and i know that
christmas is coming up around the corner
yep um so i just i want to be as
supportive as i can
so kevin you are husband of the year
good for you brother for
just wanting to be there for your wife
and for recognizing you're an advice
giver and a fixer and that's not what's
going to help in this moment
awesome all right so here's what your
wife is feeling all of that
she is grieving a fantasy that is dead
and gone
and the fantasy is most people's
wish what should be is that our moms are
there for us
they're whole they're connected they
show up to a warm house with a fire and
great food over thanksgiving
and your wife's mother is in rehab
again is disconnected because she
brought alcohol into your home in
violation of the boundaries you drew for
her
so your wife is grieving she is sad her
fantasy is
busted up she misses her mom and that
just sucks
and then you are astute man christmas
comes on the same day every year so here
it comes
so here's what i want you to do today
i want you to tell your your wife that
you want to have a conversation about
christmas
and her mom and you want to do it in a
couple of days
and i want you to ask your wife to write
your mom a letter that she's
i mean write her mom a letter that she's
never gonna send
a letter about how she feels a letter
about how she misses her
a letter about what she's missing with
her grandkids
in a letter that says i hope that we can
reconcile someday but not now
and i want your wife to write that
letter and then she's going to read it
to you
she's going to read it to you so she's
going to be vulnerable and open with you
she's going to read that letter to you
and then you guys are going to make a
plan for christmas
together and your wife is going to
inform that
of course you know where you want it to
head where you want it to be
but she's going to inform the season
and it's not going to include her mom
and you're going to hold her hands
during this process and just look her in
the eye and say this sucks and i'm sorry
and what you're doing for her is you're
creating
space you are moving things out of the
way so your wife can have space to
grieve
and just be sad and here's the thing
kevin this may just be a sad season
this may be the season where the fantasy
the the the the luster the shine is
is wearing off and this is just going to
be what this is going to be
at least for 2020 maybe for 2021
maybe forever and so by
writing a a letter to her mom she gets
all these thoughts that are weighing her
down
she gets them out of her head and on
paper they're directed to a person
and by saying them to you y'all are
going to have a connection a
vulnerability connection an
intimacy connection and she's going to
say the words out loud
mom here's how i feel
here's what you're missing here's where
i'm pissed off here's where i
hate what you have done and here's where
i hope deeply that we can come back
together someday
and then y'all are going to plan out
what christmas is going to be and then
you're going to have to make space for
your wife just to be sad this season
she'll be joyful but this is going to be
a season for sadness
and what we're hope that we're going to
plan we're going to hope that that plan
will help
but you're going to have to work on you
this season kevin because your wife's
just going to have to grieve this
so the greatest thing you can do is
create space give her the opportunity to
tell her you're there for tell that you
love when you're supporting her
take a deep breath drop your shoulders
and then head on into the season kevin
i'm i'm proud of you you're a good
husband good for you and let's get
through this
all of us together